[Música]
muchas gracias
en nuestro día a día creo firmemente que
la rutina que tenemos de casa al trabajo
del trabajo a casa y poco más nos está
impidiendo ver todos los cambios que se
están produciendo en nuestra sociedad de
manera detallada algunos cambios como
visto por hoy en medicina en tecnología
son para bien pero en algunos aspectos
de esta sociedad es estamos
retrocediendo y mucho y nos damos cuenta
quiero hablar lo que uno de los temas en
los que estamos retrocediendo por
desgracia cada vez más y no solo en este
país que es la libertad de expresión
cada prácticamente cada semana estamos
viendo en televisión como artistas
escritores músicos cantantes
son como mínimo linchados mediáticamente
por sus palabras por su letras de las
canciones
y digo como mínimo porque tenemos ya
gente que pueda acabar en la cárcel
gente que ha tenido que exiliarse
y en definitiva estamos dando respecto a
los artistas en este país
una malísima imagen lo que es a nivel
internacional y a nivel europeo
no solo a gente conocida
le puede pasar lo que es grave censurada
y en un juicio
a mí me pasó hace tres años que fui con
20 años detenida con 21 condenada y con
22 absuelta
por escribir en twitter chistes sobre
carrero blanco'
fue a priori es algo absurdo
cuando toca contarlo
pero la sensación que ocurre cuando
vives eso es en primer lugar nunca
piensas que te puede ocurrir a ti nunca
piensas que algo que le está ocurriendo
a
a gente que se puede encarar el humor a
cosas más políticamente correctas
no piensas que eso pueda pasar una
persona del día a día
yo a un 13 de abril del 2016 con la
única preocupación de mi cabeza te voy a
suspender el examen que tengo y acabó
detenida y puesta en libertad hasta la
fecha del juicio
por lo que contado por hacer bromas en
twitter
a partir de ahí cuando te ocurre eso el
mundo cambia completamente
empiezas a tener qué
y mirar cómo vas a defenderte legalmente
a qué condenas te puedes enfrentar
porque puedes acabar en la cárcel una
inhibida inhabilitación que puede
joderte básicamente la vida
en definitiva tu vida cambia como tu
vida cambia completamente
y tu principal preocupación pasa a ser
que va a ser de mí
yo por suerte a nivel y acabé absuelta
como ha comentado en lo que yo llamo una
victoria personal
fue personal porque a mí el tribunal
supremo me absolvió
porque decía que los chistes que haya
contado eran muy repetitivos
eran algo que se había dicho siempre y
que no suponía ninguna amenaza
realmente que me absuelvan por este
hecho no es ninguna victoria para la
libertad de expresión
porque no está diciendo que podamos
decir lo que queramos está diciendo que
podéis hacer esto después de haber hecho
pasar a esta chica dos años de calvario
pero actualmente tenemos como he
comentado gente condenada que cualquiera
de vosotros repitiera las letras de las
canciones los chistes que ha hecho
acabar irse en la cárcel o condenados
como esas personas
siempre se me viene a
a la cabeza cuando hablo de la censura
que hay dos tipos de censura
la que estamos viviendo por parte de lo
que es un estado y unas organizaciones
estatales que a mi parecer creo que
quieren acabar con lo que es un
pensamiento disidente
al final del todo creo que
simplemente para acabar con eso hay que
luchar en la calle
y no botar a la gente
promueve esas políticas
podemos pensar que esto puede ser una
fase que esto no puede ir más allá que
se va a solucionar a mí cuando me dicen
eso se me viene a la mente el caso de
una trabajadora alemana una fábrica de
munición en 1944
a sus compañeras de curro les contó un
chiste sobre hitler el sistema en
cuestión era este
se suben hitler y su mano derecha caring
a una torre de radio alemana
y hitler le pregunta getting que podría
hacer yo que podría decir para animar el
pueblo y garín le contesta pues pregunta
saltar
este chiste
provocó que la trabajadora fuera
fusilado
porque bien soy yo que la trabajadora a
pesar del régimen en el que vivía muda
debes hacer el chiste
porque vivía ella venía de otro sistema
la repubblica de guaymas que dentro de
los estándares de la época había
relativa libertad de expresión sin darse
cuenta me había pasado a un régimen en
el que ya no había libertad de expresión
en un régimen en el que sacado con su
vida por hacer un chiste sin saber ella
los cambios que se habían producido
no creo que llegamos al punto de que
alguien acabe fusilado por expresar su
opinión por suerte en este país hemos
pasado hemos pasado esa época
pero si bien es cierto hasta hace 4 días
no coincidíamos en este país que alguien
pudiera acabar exiliado o condenada por
una canción por un chiste incluso gente
que puede entrar en la cárcel
hace poco leí en twitter el tweet de un
cómico ricky car vice
que decía que si algo te ofende no
significa que tengas razón porque hay
gente a la que le ofende la sexualidad
las personas realizadas las personas sin
género significa que esas personas
tienen razón
con esto vengo a hablar también de otra
censura que llaman más minoritaria que
es la que intentamos alguna gente
intenta ejercer contra el vecino
comentario si no te gusta una palabra
y ya no es un estado actuando de oficio
como ha ocurrido conmigo otra gente es
una persona en un juzgado queriendo que
otra persona se calle
no pienso que la solución
a lo que no nos puede gustar o nos pueda
parecer absurdo o racista o lo que sea
llevar a una persona adjunta al juzgado
por ello en primer lugar porque si tú lo
haces te lo pueden hacer a ti no tienes
ni idea de qué estándares va a seguir un
juez para condenar a condenar te
y esa persona tampoco va a cambiar de
opinión porque le pongas una multa o le
pondré esa cárcel sino más bien se va a
reafirmar en ello
pienso que todas las personas que
estamos aquí tenemos una mentalidad más
o menos progresista que si alguien dicen
un chiste racista pues no nos haría
gracia si alguien hiciera algún chito
sobre más solita tampoco nos haría
gracia y creo que nadie aquí
si escuchara eso debería denunciar a esa
persona por los motivos que he dado
pienso que para acabar con lo que nos
pueda parecer que es malo de cara a la
sociedad que no aporta nada
es hacer como en aquel capítulo de los
simpsons en el que spring files invadido
por monstruos de la publicidad
y lo que hacen para acabar con esos
monstruos es ignorarlos cantando la
canción a los monstruos no mirar en este
caso si escuchamos opiniones monólogos
de comedia que nos pueden parecer
racistas o que insultan a ciertos
colectivos lo que vamos a hacer es
ignorar en ver a los monstruos no mirar
a los tontos no mirar pienso que es el
único paso que nos puede quedar
porque si acabamos unos a otros
denunciando
yo digo como estudiante de historia que
podemos acabar en una época muy oscura
como ya hemos vivido antes con una línea
de pensamiento único
tiene invitados a reflexionar sobre cómo
acabaríamos en una sociedad así
y cómo
como ya tenemos límites ya sean sociales
o políticos para limitar las expresiones
que puedan realmente hacer hacer daño
ser horrible
así que lo dicho os invito a reflexionar
sobre por qué no deberíamos censurar al
vecino y cómo debemos acabar con una
censura estatal que pienso que nos está
estresando como sociedad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]